[موسيقى]
نبدأ رحلتنا في الغابات الخلفية
بولاية تينيسي ومدينة هيد ستيت بارك المجمدة
حيث يوجد كل عام سباق صعب للغاية
لم ينهيه سوى 15 شخصًا فقط
مرحبًا بكم في ماراثون بيركلي.
تمتلئ عطلة نهاية الأسبوع في بيركلي بالضغوط وعدم
اليقين من أن عدم اليقين يبدأ
بمحاولة الدخول في السباق لهذا السباق ،
ومن الأسرار كيفية الاشتراك
في أكبر عقبة قبل أن
تصل إلى خط البداية وهي معرفة
كيفية الوصول إلى خط البداية إلى  يجب على
المتسابقين الذين يأملون أن يقدموا مقالًا
عن سبب حصولهم على فرصة
المنافسة ولكن العملية سرية للغاية
، ولا يوجد حتى موقع ويب خاص بالسباق من بين
آلاف الإدخالات ، حيث يتم اختيار 40 عداءًا فقط ، ويتم
اختيار بعض أفضل
لاعبي التحمل
في العالم لتجربتها  لإكمال خمس حلقات طولها 20 ميلاً
من التضاريس شديدة الانحدار التي لا تحمل علامات ولا تحتوي على
أي شيء سوى خريطة وبوصلة ، ولكن بالنسبة
لهؤلاء المتسابقين ، فهي ليست مسافة المائة
ميل  في يجعل هذا السباق صعبًا للغاية ، حيث تسير كل حلقة
في اتجاه مختلف ، لذا فإن السباق
الذي تكون فيه نوعًا ما من الجري
في الغابة لا تعرف ما إذا كنت على
الطريق الصحيح أم لا ، فإنه يضيف
عنصرًا عقليًا آخر بالكامل ، أعني أنني  لقد قرأت
نوعًا من جميع تقارير السباق المتاحة
على الإنترنت ، لذا أعلم أن
بعض الأشخاص حصلوا على تجربة مجنونة ، وبعض
الأشخاص لديهم نشأة رائعة
ورأوا أشخاصًا ومنازل حيث
كانوا مجرد أشجار ، كل شيء حدث
، مؤسس السباق ، جاري كانتريل أو
لقد صمم لاس كما هو معروف السباق بعد أن
علم عن قاتل جيمس إيرل راي مارتن
لوثر كينغ جونيور
ومحاولته الهروب من سجن قريب
بسبب التضاريس الصعبة
بعد حوالي 55 ساعة كان راي قد قطع
ثمانية أميال فقط قبل أن يتم
القبض عليه ، تشاهد الأفلام
وهم  تطارد الرجل
بالكلاب وتعتقد أنه سيكون من الممتع
حقًا معرفة ما إذا كان بإمكانك الهروب طالما
كانوا سيضعونك في السجن إذا
فشلت ومن البداية  يهيئك السباق
للفشل ، ولا يوجد وقت محدد لبدء
العد التنازلي ، ويمكن أن يبدأ في
أي وقت من منتصف الليل حتى الظهر ،
تشير البداية إلى صدفة المحارة هذه
التي تخبر المتسابقين أن أمامهم ساعة
للاستعداد وبمجرد أن يشعل Laz
سيجارته ، يكون المتسابقون
يجب أن يكمل المتسابقون كل حلقة في غضون 12 ساعة من
الزيادات أو أنهم غير مؤهلين على
طول الطريق الذي يتعين عليهم فيه جمع صفحات من
13 كتابًا مخفيًا لإثبات أنهم بقوا في
المسار
الصحيح ، فهو يعتبر أحد أصعب السباقات ، لذا فهي
طريقة لاختبار نفسك  وقدراتك الخاصة ،
نحن جميعًا نبحث فقط عن حدودنا في
البحث لنرى ما نحن قادرون عليه
لأنك لا تعرف حقًا مقدار
ما يمكنك التعامل معه حتى يصل إلى
1500 قدم فوق
Gary Cantrell  يغير المسار حسب
الضرورة لجعل الأمر أكثر صعوبة في أي وقت
ينتهي فيه شخص ما لأنه يحاول
بكلماته الخاصة أن يبقيه في
حدود ما يمكن
إزالة مواقع الكتب حوله قليلاً ،
فقط قم بأشياء مختلفة
لتعديله بحيث تضطر إلى التكيف والتعديل
أثناء التنقل ، نوع
الضرب الجسدي المذهل الذي يتعرض له هؤلاء
الأشخاص ويخرجون إلى هناك اثني عشر وأربعًا وستة عشر
ساعة تشعر بالبلل أنت تشعر بالبرد تشعر
بالجوع كلما طال الوقت  بعد ذلك
يصبح الأمر عقليًا ، حيث يؤدي الحرمان من النوم في
النهاية إلى جعل الصعوبة
العقلية لفعل ذلك مساوية أو أسوأ من
الصعوبة الجسدية التي لا يمكنك التفكير فيها إلى
أي مدى عليك أن تذهب في
الحلقة بأكملها لأنه قد يستغرق ساعات
أعني الحلقة الثانية  أعتقد أني استغرقت
21 ساعة هذا العام أي ما يقرب
من يوم واحد في الغابة بدون
وسائل راحة ، لذا عليك
فقط المضي قدمًا خطوة بخطوة في كل مرة
كتاب واحد في كل مرة يتسلق فيه واحدًا في كل
مرة حتى أكثر  العدائين الفائقين
البارعين قد تبدو الدورة مستحيلة مع
ترك خيار واحد فقط وقد
اتخذت قرارًا
بإخراج نفسي من هنا ،
كل شخص لديه هذا الأمر في حد ذاته ، وهذا
يحاول حقًا توفير
فرصة لهم لتحقيقه  الخروج في نقطة
تضيع فيها أو حيث واجهت بعض
الأخطاء ، سيكون من
المستحيل جسديًا أن تتعرف على الكتاب 11
الذي يمكننا أن نجد أنه يبدو أنني
لن أجعله للأسف
سيكون رائعًا إذا استطاع الجميع الحصول عليه  هذا
السعر ولكن الطبيعة السعر هو أنه
لا يمكنك أن تمطر الطبيعة الأم هذا العام
على المسار الذي يعيث فسادًا
للعدائين الذين فاتهم
الموعد النهائي الذي حصلوا على توقيع باركليز
ولكن كل عام يكون نوعًا مختلفًا من
القلب ولكن هذا  الطقس أعني أنه يمكنك أن
ترى أنه عام صعب للغاية ، فهذه هي
المرة الرابعة التي أقوم فيها بالسباق ، وهذا هو
أسوأ أداء لي حتى الآن ، لذا بالنظر إلى
أي شخص آخر وكيف فعلوا ذلك ، لا
أشعر بالسوء الشديد لأفضل عداء هذا العام
أنهى ثلاث حلقات فقط مرة أخرى
سيعود شعب باركليز حياً
وربما يضر بأرواحهم ولكن
جسديًا بالأشياء التي سيتعافون منها
[الموسيقى]